this is one of Delta's largest kitchen
facilities in America
around 3 200 first-class meals and
flight fuel boxes are prepared and
packaged daily for domestic flights out
of Atlanta's Hartsfield-Jackson airport
and thanks to a recent 54 million
renovation and a partnership with
catering company new rust Delta is
testing out these new robotic machines
helping the team of 1100 employees get
everything ready by takeoff
the 120 000 square foot facility can be
broken down into several stations so
everything you see in this fridge was
delivered this morning and it will go
through production and will be on
flights today
um if not the latest tomorrow the
kitchen gets its full order of meals 24
hours before a flight we've got
receiving dates on the container and
that's where it then goes through into
the first process of the production raw
ingredients are soaked in a sanitizing
solution for 90 seconds and anyone
handling food suits up
then goes through a hand and shoe wash
before heading to the core of the
facility the hot and cold kitchens here
chefs have to prep and cook nearly 40
different meal components on average the
facility can go through about 400 pounds
of cherry tomatoes and 5 100 pounds of
broccolini in a month I would say the
most challenging aspect is is the scale
of our business part of the 54 million
dollar renovation included industrial
appliances to shorten cook times like
this multifunctional pressurized brat
pan Which can cook 40 pounds of orzo in
15 minutes and these rational Ovens that
can be programmed to monitor the
temperature of the food inside to ensure
a proper cook
timing is key everything needs to be
packed for delivery by takeoff so we're
here in our production area
um as you see here we have a screen uh
which gives us basically a status update
on all of our flight departures so you
can see here um the dock will tell us
exactly which stock that flight will
depart from which Chuck number has been
assigned to that departure KRT stands
for kitchen ready time so that will tell
us exactly when we have to have all of
our flights ready all of the equipment
all of the food packed ready to be
departed exactly at that time to ensure
we have an on-flight on-time departure
each station in the production area is
dedicated to packaging one specific dish
with a visual reference the food is one
hour maximum that can be out on the
tables for production we then actually
make sure that we keep that maintain
that temperature for tray assembly the
team gets a helping hand from this
automated robot system we just started
the journey a few months ago and with
robotics we can get consistency on that
tray which frees us up for our people
and the people in the the kitchen to go
and make sure that the quality is there
and the safety is there as well a Delta
representative said the company looked
to robotics to take over repetitive
tasks like assembling on-flight trays on
one side food is placed onto a conveyor
belt and stamped with the date of when
the meal was made on the other the robot
places Cutlery napkins and side dishes
in one hour the robot can assemble 750
trays finally the trays are packed into
the carts which have been sanitized in
this steam-powered machine at 170
degrees Fahrenheit and in a single hour
this machine can clean around 250 cards
by the end of the day the facility will
break down then rebuild up to 8 100
carts and carriers once the meals are
packed into the clean carts they're held
in a refrigerated holding space until
they are loaded into insulated trucks
for final transport the trucks are
coming in and out to and from aircraft
all day every day loads start at 4 AM
and end at 9 30 PM their final
destination some 350 flights a day
where hot meals are heated up in Flight
a Delta representative said that this
facility could be the facility of the
future combining technology with a human
Workforce the company declined to state
where they might roll out the robotic
equipment in the future we're in the
food business 60 million meals a year
for us it's the future is all about just
continuing to innovate in that space
whether it's new equipment in our
kitchens down to really personalization
for the customer Delta did not provide
comment on how the food and beverage
program affects ticket prices but its
food offerings depend on a few things
how long your flight is your travel
class and what city you're flying out of
and as long as planes are flying this
facility won't stop they're making meals
seven days a week all year round